bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 29 juin
2015 merci de nous rejoindre sur tv fil
78 pour une nouvelle édition du journal
de la rédaction voici les principaux
titres que nous allons développer
jusqu'à 38 degrés 40 degrés mercredi
dans les yvelines nous connaîtrons cette
semaine un phénomène qui n'avait pas été
observé à cette période de l'année
depuis plus de 60 ans selon météo france
la commission des citoyens pour les
droits de l'homme vient d'organiser à
paris une marche contre les abus
psychiatriques les manifestants
dénoncent les internements de force ou
encore les traitements dégradants
manifestation qui fait écho à une action
menée en début d'année à plaisir nous en
privons avec sa présidente et puis le
festival solidays a battu des records de
fréquentation
un festival francilien où de nombreux
yvelinois étaient présents côté
organisation les enfants et les
personnes âgées sont les plus
vulnérables aux fortes chaleurs en 2003
la canicule avait fait et 15000 morts
pour protéger les anciens de ces fortes
températures les maisons de retraite ont
pris des dispositions exemple dans
l'établissement korian qui est à 7 à
montigny le bretonneux avec lionel 13 et
le diwan savez il va faire très chaud
cette semaine oui région
à la maison de retraite korian qui est à
montigny-le-bretonneux le sujet est sur
toutes les lèvres
il faut se préparer à une vague de
grande chaleur d'autant plus que les
personnes âgées sont plus vulnérables
des jalons des polypathologies
cardiaques respiratoires diabète qui est
en plus vulnérables d hydratation la
personne âgée à une sens n'a plus une
sensation de soif comme on peut avoir
plus jeunes elles ont des traitements
qui parfois peuvent aggraver la
déshydratation tout ce qui est
traitement neuroleptique antidiabétique
antihypertenseurs pour parer aux fortes
chaleurs chaque été l'établissement met
en place un plan canicule
du 1er juin au 31 août il sourd ce qu'on
appelle en veille sanitaire
c'est un système qui permet d'anticiper
des mettre en place des mesures
préventives de personnes et former en
permanence
il est fort mais plus particulièrement a
vendu par le médecin coordinateur avec
des mesures d'hydratation des mesures de
surveillance de plus en charge
l'hydratation un litre et demi par jour
et par personne le maître mot du
personnel durant tout l'été un personnel
chargé également de donner des douches
d'être vigilant sur l'habillage des
résidents de façon légère et en
privilégiant le coton ou encore
d'orienter l'alimentation vers des
nutriments aux apports hydriques plus
important il faut aussi dépister les
premiers signes de déshydratation
quelqu'un qui était apathique qui
devient un peu agressif ou l' inverse
ensuite il ya les maux de tête
modification des constantes la
température qu'il augmente la fréquence
cardiaque et augmente la tension qui
baissent tout ce qui est troubles
digestifs vomissements diarrhées les
malaises
la climatisation est d'ores et déjà en
marche dans des pièces de
l'établissement
ici on est prêt à affronter la chaleur
et face à cette vague de chaleur
annoncée pour les prochains jours quels
sont les bons gestes à adopter que vous
soyez âgées ou non voici quelques
conseils avec ce sujet quand on accélère
bas je ferme le valais et détecte et en
grèce auprès voilà boire beaucoup moins
c'est 2 litres d'eau par jour voilà oui
éviter de sortir entre 12h et 16h je me
désaltère sait tous que ça ça fait on se
protège du soleil en restant à
l'intérieur des gestes simples et bien
connu il va falloir les adopter dès
demain une vague de chaleur
exceptionnelle est annoncé avec des
températures avoisinant les 40 degrés du
jamais vu depuis 60 ans à cette période
de l'année
ce matin déjà les clients se préparer on
a eu plus de monde ce matin donc on
présume effectivement que les gens vont
rester au frais cet après-midi parce
qu'on avait vraiment influent inhabituel
pour un pourri matinée ouais on attend
par exemple 38 degrés mercredi dans les
yvelines les bons réflexes à adopter
rester dans un endroit frais plusieurs
heures par jour
éviter de sortir aux heures les plus
chaudes limiter les efforts physiques
mais surtout boire beaucoup s'hydrater
énormément régulièrement souvent
s'hydrater en buvant s'hydrater part à
l'aide de brumisateurs strates et la
peau voilà surtout être vigilant avec
les enfants en bas âge et les personnes
âgées qui sont les personnes les plus
sensibles à la déshydratation
la plateforme téléphonique canicule info
service vous informe également du lundi
au samedi de 8h à 20h
on passe à l'invité du journal à présent
millan escudier bonsoir 7 la présidente
de la commission des citoyens pour les
droits de l'homme la ccdh vous venez
d'organiser une marche sur paris samedi
dernier une marche contre les abus
psychiatriques internement de force
traitements dégradants dépistage des
enfants est mise sous camisole chimique
ça fait partie des points que vous
entendez dénoncé avant de rentrer plus
dans le détail expliquez-nous déjà
pourquoi
votre inquiétude pourquoi un tel
mouvement alors si vous voulez
l'association donc la commission des
citoyens pour les droits de l'homme
l'association que je préside existe
depuis plus de 40 ans en france dans le
but de dénoncer les violations des
droits de l'homme ondh c4i faut savoir
qu'on reçoit de nombreux témoignages de
personnes victimes d'hospitalisation
abusif de mise en soins sous contrainte
abusives ou de mauvais traitements dans
les établissements psychiatriques comme
la mise en contention en chambre
d'isolement ou encore des électrochocs
faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 70
mi séance d'électrochocs chaque année en
france donc d'autant plus si c'était la
raison cette manifestation de samedi qui
a réuni plus d'un millier de
manifestants de montparnasse à saint
michel c'est pour sauver si je puis dire
ou protéger les enfants d'abus
psychiatrique parce qu'il ya une
tendance au jour d'aujourd'hui à
dépister à tout-va notamment les enfants
d'hyperactif et à les mettre sous
ritaline justement voit les images de
cette mobilisation on va s'attarder sur
cette question des enfants dans un
instant juste sur le constat que vous
faites vous mener des enquêtes d étude
pour chiffrer un petit peu la situation
que ce soit au niveau national ou
départementales oui alors nous demandons
auprès de chaque commission
départementale des soins psychiatriques
leurs statistiques d'hospitalisation
sous contrainte
ce qui nous permet de savoir exactement
où on en interne le plus où on
hospitalise le plus où on met en soins
sous contrainte
le plus en france par département et au
niveau national où ça permet de savoie
de comparer la france aussi à d'autres
pays européens
faut savoir qu'on interne à deux à trois
fois plus que dans la majorité des pays
européens
donc en france en plus de consommer
beaucoup de drogues psychiatriques
en interne aussi beaucoup donc nous
sommes sûrement pas fou plus fou que nos
amis allemands ou anglais ou espagnol
mais en tout cas c'est vrai qu'en france
il ya une vraie tendance à tout
psychiatrisés c'est dû à quoi on a bu il
ya un vrai lobbying de l'industrie
pharmaceutique il faut pas se leurrer il
est là il est
il est certain vous avez notamment
l'association hyper super tdh france qui
est une association qui est financée par
le laboratoire shire laboratoire qui
commercialise le kws intel et vicky vale
en de la ritaline donc la ritaline qui
est un psychostimulant qu'on prescrit
aux enfants soit disant hyperactif qui
est proche de la cocaïne
et cette association a demandé tout
récemment à la haute autorité de santé
de faire un rapport justement sur
l'hyperactivité des enfants et la
nécessité de dépister des plus jeune âge
mais la dangerosité de ce rapport c'est
qu'ils préconisent plusieurs grands
grandes choses notamment des dépistages
le plus précoce possible dans les écoles
de façon à dépister à trouver si je puis
dire a été étiqueté les enfants
hyperactifs
mais ce qui est très inquiétant c'est
que ces enfants hyperactifs qui sont
souvent un petit peu plus agité que les
autres ou peut être plus créatifs ou
peut-être plus intelligent que d'autres
on va les étiqueter malade mental avis
une étiquette avis et en plus de ça on
va aller leur donner un psychostimulant
proches de la cocaïne qui est classé par
l'onu dans la même cote est catégorique
le crystal meth ou le speed
donc c'est un vrai psychotropes a été
mieux en début d'année parlait justement
de votre mobilisation il avait eu
notamment devant l'établissement de
plaisir par exemple c'était au tout
début de cette année 2015 il ya une
évolution depuis on me disait quand on
discutait pour préparer l'entretien que
ça n'allait pas mieux au contraire l
internement de force oui alors le
problème c'est que la loi a été réformé
ans en septembre 2011 et en juillet 2013
et il faut savoir que depuis ces
réformes de la loi sur l'hospitalisation
sous contrainte il ya de plus en plus
d'internement alors qu'à la base ces
lois ont été votées mis en place pour
diminuer le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées son consentement
donc nous on constate une recrudescence
d'utilisation des procédures dites
d'urgence ou de péril imminent et par
rapport au département des yvelines faut
savoir que la situation est
particulièrement inquiétante parce que
dans les hôpitaux et c'est la raison de
nos manifestations il ya quelques mois
et là on va re manifestée cet été parce
que la situation n'a pas évolué
positivement
il ya toujours beaucoup
d'hospitalisation et beaucoup de mesures
dites d'urgence ou péril imminent qui
sont utilisés dans ces hôpitaux mais
parce qu'à un moment c'est abusif c'est
à dire que même pour être très clair
aujourd'hui vous demander l'interdiction
complète de ces internement de force
contre la volonté en tout cas la
personne concernée ou alors qu'ils aient
plus de contrôle dessus visibilité il
faut qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de
contrôle savez en prison je prends
toujours l'exemple des prisons nous a
énormément de contrôle dans les prisons
et pourtant ce sont des personnes qui
ont été privés de leurs libertés les
plus fondamentales parce qu'ils ont
commis un crime ou un délit faut savoir
comme si catherine la personne
absolument rien commis et elle est
pourtant privée de ses libertés les plus
fondamentales parfois protégés pour la
protéger elle même aussi oui alors mais
il faut savoir que vous avez les
hospitalisations à la demande du préfet
donc sur arrêté préfectoral est
statistiquement parlant vous invite très
peu comparé aux hospitalisation à la
demande d'un tiers
donc il faut savoir que la même dans les
yvelines mais c'est un sujet inquiétant
qu'il faut réformer qu'il faut changer
c'est que vous avez les utilisations
d'urgence et sans même la corde un
membre de la famille donc un seul
psychiatre privé n'importe quel citoyen
de ses libertés et vous avez
l'utilisation massive de ces procédures
dans le département des forêts poste de
contrôle le supplice de contrôle voilà
exactement est beaucoup plus d'humanité
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques
parce que vous avez un brillant
économiste le docteur jean-louis cas
comeau qui est professeur d'économie à
l'université de perpignan qui à faire un
discours lors d'une autre manifestation
de samedi
faut savoir qu'il a été hospitalisé du
jour au lendemain privé de sa liberté
interne est menacée de traitement par
électrochocs enfermé pendant un an à
consommer une quinzaine de psychotropes
par jour procédure autour de ça oui tout
à fait d'accord c'est dieu voilà par le
directeur de l'établissement dans lequel
il exerçait qui avait fait cette demande
là d'internement et c'est encore en
cours de traitement par la justice
exactement donc ça va faire encore
exactement en tout cas on aide
activement cette personne parce que être
interné par son propre employeur c'est
quand même une grande première et c'est
totalement illégal
donc on va l'aider à obtenir c'est c'est
dommage et intérêt comme il se doit les
gens là est la procédure est en cours
voilà il ya aussi le fait vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure que la france soit
d un des pays donc les plus hypes
cicatriser mais aussi où l'on consomme
le plus de psychotropes nous sommes
allés faire un petit micro-trottoir
savoir comment les gens percevait ça
justement
ben moi je pense que des antidépresseurs
c'est une bonne chose pour certaines
personnes dont c'est une maladie
chronique ou quoi que ce soit je pense à
presse et des médecins qui gèrent ça
mieux que tout le monde donc je pense
qu'on peut pas forcément jugé est ce
qu'un médecin dit ou quoi que ce soit je
sais pas peut pas juger les gens
bon il ya un malaise c'est sûr peut-être
que les gens sont
quand il ya trop stressé ou peut-être
ont recours aux halles antidépresseurs
un peu rapidement une idée sur la
question moi j'en prends pas si la
moyenne la consommation mondiale est
inférieure à la nôtre on peut se
remettre en question je pense que de
temps ce pays a une grosse influence de
laboratoires pharmaceutiques sur sur les
médecins et que progressivement salaire
de l'année un petit peu mieux on voit
certains généralistes qui vont savoir
une plus grande conscience de leur part
de responsabilité là dedans et je pense
que progressivement ça va ça va aller en
s'améliorant
je pense que vous rejoignez le dernier
témoignage oui tout à fait il faut
savoir que les autorités de santé la
haute autorité de santé l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament qui
sont les deux plus hautes instances de
santé dans notre pays sont beaucoup
controversé en ce moment parce qu'il
faut savoir que et notamment médiapart
qui a enquêté sur les conflits
d'intérêts de leurs experts leur médecin
qui autorise la mise sur le marché du
médicament ou qui décide des taux de
remboursement de psychotropes et il faut
savoir que la grande majorité de ces
experts sont financés par des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
et donc nous si vous voulez en tant
qu'association droits de l'homme
on dénonce très fortement se sait confie
l'intérêt est là la ministre de la santé
à d'ailleurs pris ce problème à coeur
parce que dans la cadre de la prochaine
réforme de santé qui sera présenté au
sénat en septembre
ils veulent augmenter les contrôles
justement dans les instances de santé
pour veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de
conflits d'intérêts ou tout du moins
beaucoup moins et donc renforcer ses
contrôles là donc nous sommes satisfaits
de ce projet de réforme
mais il ya encore beaucoup à faire parce
que quand on parlait de la personne
parler des médecins généralistes les
médecins généralistes restent les plus
gros prescripteurs d'antidépresseurs en
france donc ça reste une mode une
une fois la médecin généraliste va être
rapide là tout de suite prescrire son
médicament miracle mais au vu des effets
secondaires très importante ces
médicaments il faut y réfléchir à deux
fois il faut surtout informer le
consommateur de des effets secondaires
lutte contre les psychotropes le
psychotrope pardon lutte contre les abus
d'internement également pour bien
comprendre le sens de votre combat je
voudrais juste tout de même précisé le
fondement même du du ccdh s'était fondée
par l'église de scientologie
donc pour être tout à fait clair quels
sont les liens que vous entretenez
aujourd'hui avec l'église de
scientologie
mais l'association été co fondée en 1969
en fait aux états unis par l'église de
scientologie un brillant professeur de
psychiatrie docteur thomas saas dans le
but justement d'assainir le domaine de
la santé mentale et de faire en sorte
que les droits fondamentaux de l'homme
soient respectés dans ce domaine et si
vous voulez historiquement parlant
fondateur de l'église de scientologie
avait lui même vu des abus en
psychiatrie dans les années 50 60 et il
a voulu dénoncer haut et fort ce qu'il a
vu et la scientologie qui est vu comme
une secte en france qui est classée
comme une secte en france il ya des
rapports entre les deux aujourd'hui
comment vous intervenez par exemple pour
être très clair le combat que vous menez
on sait que l'église de scientologie
n'est pas pour justement de tout ce qui
est psychiatre et psychotropes et autres
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous officiez pour
l'église de scientologie très clairement
leur faut savoir que l'association est
une associée à des pendants de l'église
de scientologie de par ses statuts d'une
association loi 1901
donc bien sûr dans l'association vous
avez nombreux scientologues qui sont des
citoyens qui considèrent que ils ont
leur responsabilité en tant que citoyen
de dénoncer ce qui se passe en matière
de violations des droits de l'homme dans
notre pays qui est la france maintenant
en termes de par rapport à la
scientologie ou savoir que vous avez
mentionné le fait que c'était une secte
mais il faut savoir c'est comme tel
c'est pas moi que là c'est classé par un
rapport parlementaire qui a été annulée
par jean pierre raffarin qui était à
l'époque premier ministre donc si vous
voulez parce qu'on ne peut pas et en
france et la séparation de l'église et
de l'état et l'état français ne pourra
jamais reconnaître une religion d'une
secte d'ailleurs parce que vous avez la
séparation de l'église et de l'état dont
vous pouvez pas avoir récemment aussi
c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que
vous ne pouvez pas officiellement dire
que la scientologie est une secte mais
il faut savoir que la scientologie est
une religion et reconnue dans comme une
religion dans de nombreux pays notamment
en angleterre en espagne au portugal et
en plateau pour parler de religion
c'était pour être très clair sans
fondement même du fait de cette
commission juste pour terminer cet
entretien sur les demandes que vous
formulez aujourd'hui je reviens la
question que vous posez tout à l'heure
c'est plus de contrôle vous interpeller
les pouvoirs publics vous avez évoqué
d'autres actions éventuellement de
sensibilisation pendant l'été oui tout à
fait en continu les actions vous savoir
que depuis le début de l'année on a fait
110 manifestations obtenu 3 millions de
visiteurs sur nos sites donc on obtient
1 on sensibilise énormément de gens on
va envoyer encore 25000 journaux sur les
abus psychiatriques à des autorités très
spécifiques qui ont pouvoir de faire
changer les choses au niveau national
donc on va continuer nos actions va
faire notamment un raid à vélo dans la
pays de la loire pour dénoncer les
pratiques qui s'y passe donc on va
continuer nos opérations de
sensibilisation sur les abus
psychiatriques
merci à mylène escudier présidente de la
commission des citoyens pour les droits
de l'homme est revenu en plateau si on
passe à la politique à présent avec
debout la france est sa tête de liste
sur notre région nicolas dupont aignan
qui est en campagne il était dans les
yvelines en fin de semaine dernière pour
évoquer la question des déplacements et
du transport mélanie poquet william l
premier déplacement pour nicolas
dupont-aignan dans les yvelines le
député maire de yerres dans l'essonne
tête de liste pour debout la france l'un
de ses axes de campagne pour les
régionales présentées ce jour là les
transports en commun et les déplacements
en voiture
il s'agit pas de dire que tout se fera
en voiture mais 70 % des déplacements en
ile-de-france se font aujourd'hui en
grande couronne en voiture et la
politique des écologistes qui consiste à
dire on n'investit plus à créer des
embouteillages et donc de la pollution
mais donc moi je propose qu'on
réinvestissent dans les infrastructures
routières à certains endroits précis
pour débloquer des bouchons à six mois
des élections régionales les différentes
formations sont en train de finaliser
leurs listes celle de debout la france
devrait être connu au mois de septembre
vous aurez des surprises puisqu'il y
aura des maires des yvelines des élus qu
en ont un peu assez du régime des partis
soit le clientélisme socialiste soit le
clientélisme ump moi je pense que enfin
république soit disant républicain je
pense que les français en ont marre de
ce jeu le permanent entre le parti
socialiste et les anciens ump je pense
qu'il faut envoyer à la région des gens
libres indépendantes lors des régionales
de 2010 debout la france déjà mené dans
notre région par nicolas dupont aignan
avait obtenu 4 % des suffrages
la création de la zone d'activité
concertée de la remise à voisins le
bretonneux a été acté jeudi dernier en
conseil communautaire par la casse qui
c'est une page importante ce qui va
s'ouvrir pour l'histoire de la commune
ce programme d'urbanisme comprend près
de 490 logements dont 36% en locatif
social et plus de 60 % en accession à la
propriété des équipements comme un pôle
petite enfance et des aménagements
paysagers sont également prévus la
future zac devra respecter les quartiers
alentour et répondre aux normes de
développement durable
une étude d'impact a été mise à la
disposition du public elle a recueilli
14 observations qui portait sur les
équipements la circulation les énergies
renouvelables le bilan sera d'ailleurs
en ligne sur le site de la ville de
voisins et de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis une autre zone d'aménagement
concertée a été créé ce jeudi soir en
conseil communautaire la zac gare bécane
à la verrière qui comprend notamment une
partie de la zone d'activités de la
jouer du quartier orly-parc il s'agit de
créer un écoquartier avec une offre de
logements diversifiés affirmé le maire
qui entend descendre en dessous des 50 %
de logements sociaux sur sa ville des
commerces des activités de services vers
est aussi le jour pour faire de ce lieu
un vrai coeur de ville 250 mille mètres
carrés le doublement du pont schuller
qui permet d'accéder à la gare ou encore
l'aménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne fait aussi partie du cahier des
charges pour favoriser le désenclavement
un projet sur 15 à 20 ans a conclu alain
âge à la tête donc de cette commune et
puis en marge de ce conseil
communautaire et de cette série de
décisions un nouveau rassemblement a eu
lieu à l'appel notamment d'alain le vote
l'ancien maire de magny les hameaux
au nom des collectifs citoyens ils
étaient une trentaine beaucoup moins que
lors de la dernière séance du conseil
syndical à le rejoindre pour demander un
moratoire pour parvenir à d'autres
solutions que les fermetures de la
maison de l'environnement
l'amour la maison de la poésie de
guyancourt il a présenté des pétitions
et en récolter de deux à trois mille
signatures rappelons que ces différentes
fermetures ont été décidées par l'équipe
majoritaire en raison des baisses des
dotations de l'état plus de 5 millions
d'euros d'économies à trouver les
missions de la maison de la poésie et de
l'environnement seront maintenus
redéployés au sein des réseaux et des
médiathèques
à noter aussi l'annoncé de la fermeture
d'une autre structure c'est l'office de
tourisme ces missions seront affectés à
la direction de la communication est la
direction des services économiques afin
à de mettre l'accent sur le tourisme
d'affaires
un tout autre sujet les solidays qui se
sont achevés hier soir le festival de
musique qui sensibilise à la lutte
contre le sida se déroule est une
nouvelle fois à l'hippodrome de
longchamp le record de fréquentation a
été battue plus de 225 mille spectateurs
sur les trois jours de festival festival
qui ne serait rien sans ses bénévoles
1500 cette année avoir donné de leur
temps et de leur énergie pour une bonne
cause portrait d'un yvelinois engagé
avec william l
bienvenue aux solidays à l'hippodrome de
longchamp transformé pour l'occasion en
gigantesque festival à ciel ouvert trois
jours de fête de concernées surtout
trois jours pour lever des fonds contre
le sida
qui
une explosion de record cette année avec
des dizaines de concerts des têtes
d'affiché de renom et plus de 225 mille
visiteurs les solidays ont engrangé une
recette de 2,6 millions d'euros une
somme qui n'auraient pas pu être levé
sans les bénévoles ils étaient 1500
cette année comme stéphane ini montain
il nous a expliqué pourquoi il a décidé
de s'inscrire
c'est l'histoire à travers et passer un
bon week-end de trois jours avec des
gens qu'on ne connaissait pas au débat
sur deux petites familles comme ça on
maintenant on commence à se connaître de
plus en plus c'est sympa et tout ça pour
défendre voilà la lutte contre le sida
donc voilà toujours sympa de faire ça
dans une bonne ambiance
être bénévole c'est de travailler tout
en s'amusant mais aussi avoir accès au
backstage une toute autre manière
d'aborder le festival
si c'est en fait c'est le qg des
bénévoles en fait c'est là on se
retrouve dès qu'on a un petit moment de
pause pour se reposer pour se retrouver
à ce que les potes de différentes
équipes
on a un endroit abrité pour manger un
peu on a aussi deux tables de ping pong
baby food et des petites tentes pour eux
dormir sont haletantes dormir c'est
vraiment le petit coin parfait pour nous
petits points privilégiés là bas
stéphane a passé l'après midi à l'entrée
du festival aux contrôles des sacs
il est temps maintenant pour lui de
s'arrêter et profiter un peu des
conseils
braqueur partie way pour faire la fête
on s'amusait dans une bonne ambiance
bonne humeur c'est super pour solidays
c'est la bonne humeur c'est la toiture
nous retrouvons stéphane le lendemain
midi cette fois ci au travail après une
longue nuit de concerts et de fête
en fait on vérifie l'est les bracelets
s'ils ont droit de rentrer voilà ce
n'est pas trois jours deux jours grâce
l'hérault c'est bon violet
merci on a bien dormi mais quand même
c'est à dire poser un bon café
c'est reparti là c'est la dernière
journée ça va
le festival financé en partie par la
région ile de france et par de nombreux
partenaires ne pourrait pas se faire
sans l'aide des bénévoles un mois de
montage est nécessaire pour toute
l'infrastructure est ici tout est fait
pour rappeler l'importance de leur
contribution
le bénévolat c'est la vitrine du
festival solidays voilà d'abord ce fait
si elle n'existerait pas sans eux
d'autre part ce fait si elle repose sur
dynamique collective
et voilà et c'est eux qui la porte c'est
vrai qu'il a qui l'a fait qui la font
vivre au quotidien dans le cadre du
festival moi j'entends que des gens
qu'ils ont un rôle bénévole vos
bénévoles ils sont formidables ils ont
le sourire donne le meilleur sur l'idée
d'un festival responsable et solidaire
qui porte des valeurs de partage ou de
montage à peine commencé la 18e édition
est déjà en préparation
les bénévoles sur les bénévoles si on va
faire un gros pot tour est super alors
parce que voilà s'en ressent vous valez
rien les gars donc merci allez encore un
petit poteau le poutou d'antoine de
caunes un dernier mot pour refermer ce
journal le gala de boxe prévu au
vélodrome nationale a été reportée
prévue le 4 juillet il se tiendra
finalement le 28 novembre huit combats
professionnels qui doivent se dérouler
dans le championnat d'europe des poids
welters ce avec le français ahmed el
moussaoui du club d'elancourt champion
en titre
officiellement les organisateurs veulent
se donner plus de temps pour préparer un
événement d'une telle ampleur j'en
profite pour vous rappeler d'ailleurs
que tous les résultats et toute
l'actualité sportive
c'est dans un instant sur tv fil 78
toujours avec michael et demi d'euros et
son 7,8 sport moi je vous retrouve
demain dès 18 heures en direct pour une
nouvelle édition du journal très belle
soirée